الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
قال زعيم دونيسكا الموالي لروسيا ان
الظروف في جبهه بخموتيه لتطويق من سماه
العدو وتضييق الحصار عليه وكان مستشار
الزعيم ادونس قال ان قوه تخوض معارك في
مركز مدينه
الطرق المؤديه الى فخمه اصبحت تحت السيطره
الناريه للقوات الروسيه على حد وصفه واوضح
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ايصال امدادات
الى داخل المدينه لكن جهودها باءت بالفشل
وتكبدت خسائر كبيره
ومن جانبه قال مؤسس شركه فاقدر يبكيني ان
معلومات الاستخباراتيه تؤكد بدء وصول
دبابات لبارد الالمانيه الى القوات
الاوكرانيه في مدينه تشادسوف المجاوره
لباخموت مؤكدا ان القوات الاوكرانيه لم
تستخدمها بعد
في الاثناء اعلنت قياده القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها الجويه دمرت احدى
عشره طائره مسيره من اصل اربع عشره هاجمت
اوكرانيا في الشمال او من الشمال خلال
الليله الماضيه مؤكده ان من بينها طائرات
مسيره هجوميه ايرانيه من نوع شاهد ومن
جانبها اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمنطقه
كيافنه 19 طائرات المسيره من طراز شاهد
اسقطت في سمائك خلال الليله الماضيه مشيره
الى ان الهجوم تم على دفعتين واكيدتان عدم
وقوع اصابات البشريه بعدما اصابه اي من
اهداف البنيه التحتيه
اعلن مركز الدفاع الاقليميه التابعه
لسلطات دونيتك المواليه لروسيا اصابه خمسه
مدنيين جراء قصف اوكراني على احياء متفرقه
في المدينه
واضف المركز ان القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت
خلال الساعه الاخيره نحو 120 قذيفه
وصاروخا باتجاه مناطق سكانيه في
المقاطعهما ادى الى تضرر ثلاثه مباني
سكنيه وعدد من منشات
ابدا معك عامر لافي والتطورات خاصه على
لسان القوات المواليه لروسيا بخصوص تطويق
نعم مياده يعني بالنسبه لتصريحات الرسميه
الاوكرانيه الصادره عن قياده الاركان لا
حديث عن هذا الموضوع ولا نفي ولا تاكيد
لهذا الموضوع فقط اكتفت قياده الاركان
بالحديث عن تمكنها من صد العديد من
الهجمات على جميع المحاور في مخمود وان
اكثر من 25 قريه في محيط هذه المدينه قصفت
بشكل عشوائي كما تقول وبمختلف انواع
الاسلحه تم قصف هذه المناطق لكن مصادرنا
في داخل مخمود تتحدث عن معارك عنيفه تدور
في جميع المحاور في الشمال وفي الشرق وفي
الجنوب ايضا لكن يبقى ان المحور الشمالي
هو المحور الاخضر والاعقد بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه وفقا لهذه المصادر تحاول
القوات الروسيه ما زالت التقدم بعد ان
سيطرت على بقريه برخيفكا ودخلت يهدنا
تحاول التقدم لسببين السبب الاول هو
الاقتراب من الاحياء الشماليه لمدينه
مخمود والسبب الثاني هو الاقت من هذا
الطريق خلفي لانه الطرق الرئيسيه التي تصل
مخموت الطريق الشمالي من سلافيانس الى
بخموت قطع فعليا من جانب القوات الروسيه
الطريق الجنوبي من كوستاريكا الى مخمود هو
مقطوع ناريه من صحه الوصف لان المعارك
قريبه منه وبالتالي لم يعد سوى هذا الطريق
هذا الطريق التفافي يمر عبر تشاصفيار الى
مدينه محمود وهو اقرب الى الشمال المدينه
وبالتالي الاقتراب من المحور الشمالي
سيمكن القوات الروسيه من الاقتراب من هذا
الطريق واغلاقه ناريا لكن مصادرنا هناك ما
زالت تؤكد ان هذا الطريق مفتوح وانه يمكن
من خلاله ايصال المساعدات والجنود ونقل
الجرحى من خلال هذا الطريق الالتفافي
الحديث ايضا طبعا كما ذكرنا ربما بالامس
اليوم اكدوا نفس المعلومه وهو زياده القصف
واستخدام الذخائر والمدفعيه بشكل كبير وهو
ما يدل كما يقول كما تقول مصادرنا بانه
انعكاس ربما لحل ازمه الذخائر التي كانت
القوات فاجنر قد تحدثت واتهمت قيادات
ووزراء في الحكومه في الحكومه الروسيه
بانها تقلل ارسال الذخار واضح كميات كبيره
من الذخائر وصلت لان القصف مستمر ليس فقط
على المحور الشمالي قصف عنيف كما يقولون
على الشمال والشرق والجنوب بالحديث على
المحور الشرقي المحور الشرقي اذا نتحدث عن
الاحياء الشرقيه للمدينه قوات الاوكرانيه
مياده موجوده في الضفه الشرقيه لنهر مخموت
لكنها باعداد قليله والان القوات الروسيه
تحاول قصف مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه لدفعها
الى الضفه الغربيه منذ فتره لكن مصادرنا
تؤكد بانها ما زالت في الضفه الشرقيه
للنهر لم تتحرك الى الضفه الغربيه وتقاتل
هناك وتكبد القوات الروسيه خسائر كبيره
على جميع هذه المحاور